today I think I started the other day
off with you and I will say it again
yeah do you know where you are and what
you're promoting thank you there's a big
sign there good yeah and Bell here to
like help me when I sleep right she we
were
I made the choice before that she's in
72 upcoming projects promoting a lot but
jumping do I get to talk to you guys
today I saw the first two episodes I
thought they were so well done and so
well written one of the things that
struck me was right from the beginning
of the first episode it jumps in and
never it just you jump in the world and
there's no exposition dumps it's just
really well-written can you talk about
the quality of the scripts through the
whole first season and the scripts Oh
Carrie Aaron yeah she really is
incredible and the strength of the
writing I mean beyond the strength of
the cast that was already you know you
know made it sort of a no-brainer and
the strength of the writing it's just so
bold and really provocative and funny
and I think it strikes that balance of
you know like real life you know it's
it's funny but it also has some really
touching moments and we'd always being
so excited to get the next step we only
got there we we got the first three
before we started and then they were
writing as we were going along so Carrie
and the writers were working literally
24/7 and then we were getting scripts
delivered to us like every two weeks so
we were like finding out as it as bit as
we're going along with filming as well
one of the things I find with first
seasons of shows is that you're kind of
figuring out the infrastructure of the
show and how to make it you know
everyone's figuring out what can you
shoot in a certain amount of days you
have and what was it like at the
beginning of this of the show when you
started filming and did it progress at
all like the way you were making it by
the end well there's always changes a
little bit because you have different
directors direct different episode so of
course there's like you know the same
kind of feel throughout the whole thing
but you know each director likes to put
their own kind of stamp on it
so the general tone obviously stays the
same but some Styles slightly changes
episode to episode which is cool and
it's quite a big ensemble as well so I
think you know every few episodes
different actors would sort of have
their sort of moment if you if if you
know what I mean in different storylines
coming to the
so you know I think I probably got you
know more stuff further down the line
you know so some some episodes you'd
have sort of a lighter time and then
then more intense one of the things I
also think about the show is it's so
timely it deals with really what's going
on right now as well as a lot more could
you sort of talk about that aspect of
the show yeah I mean it's amazing the
whole sort of posed me to conversation
and I think also the fact that the show
really is you know run by women you know
I don't just carry Erin you know the
writer but me me leader you know the
lead director so many female directors
and Jen and Reese's as producers of the
show so yeah it's a real privilege to
work on something that's so current and
I think that they dealt with them me to
kind of conversation in a really
interesting way it's not just black and
white it's not like villain or
perpetrator and victim it's kind of
about the umbrella issue and the kind of
cultural conversation that we're having
it delves very very deep into that
conversation if I'm not mistaken you are
you worked on Judd Apatow Staten Island
yeah what was I'm a huge Judd Apatow fan
and I am a big Pete Davidson fan what
was it like being a part of that project
it was I mean it was so weak so I went
from shooting the morning shows straight
that and they couldn't have been more
different
I mean Judge movie was all improvised
comedy but yeah it was it was so much
fun okay I'm so looking forward to that
and my last thing for you guys what can
you tease it's so interesting no it's
hard to get a one season pick up but
this show was picked up for two years
what is it like working on a show where
it could you know what I mean like being
a part of something like this I think
like it's well you know we don't know
what's gonna happen
story-wise after season one but I think
the exciting thing is because it's about
the morning music it could go in any
direction these people are dealing with
different situations 24/7 every day is
different so why not be excited to see
what happens next season and also being
part of Apple's first batch of shows you
know is so exciting I think because you
know a new streaming service you know
obviously ever you know the iPhone Apple
you know has such a huge reach so I
think it's it's really just a privilege
to be there right at the beginning
I got to stop I'm just gonna say it
Congrats on the show I cannot wait to
finish it up